now that apple announced their new
phones everybody is focusing on all the
specs and updates of the iphone 13s
completely ignoring the big features
that were leaked patented and more that
we were looking forward to and i'm also
really excited for these phones and some
of these features aren't big deals but
others would have been amazing to have
and apple is likely saving them for the
iphone 13 models next year so that we
have another reason to upgrade so let's
go ahead and go over all of them
including some really weird limitations
of the iphone 13. the first one is the
notch apple has changed it for the first
time ever and now made it more narrow
this year so much so that it's actually
slightly taller
overall it is 20 smaller which gives us
a bit more screen real estate especially
on the right and left side of the notch
unfortunately for some reason they
aren't making any use of this extra
space and we are still limited to seeing
a less detailed battery indicator and
having to swipe down into control center
to see the percentage when there is
clearly enough space to add this info or
at least something else hopefully apple
will fix this with a software update and
allow us to make use of that extra space
that we are paying for by having a
taller notch this year compared to
previous ones now we have another
authentication method not only rumored
for the iphone 13 but backed up by two
patents the apple received and that is
the under display fingerprint scanner
face id is amazing and very convenient
but there are times that fingerprint
scanners work better and some people
just prefer them info came out that
apple actually tested iphone 13s within
screen touch id but as we know the
iphone 13s didn't end up receiving them
it seems like apple is still planning on
implementing this but only for future
iphones and that they decided to work on
under display face id for the higher end
iphones and to use under display touch
id for the lower end models once they
get rid of the notch so if you're
somebody that want a touch id in a pro
iphone it likely won't ever happen
another thing that likely won't ever
happen is getting a better port on the
iphones we had rumors of usb type c
coming to iphone pros a while ago and to
make it line up with their other devices
like the macbooks and ipads but nope
apple is still sticking with lightning
all while at the same time changing even
their second cheapest ipad to usb type-c
by this point we can pretty much bet
that usb type-c will never hit iphones
or else apple would have done it by now
but the other rumor also didn't show and
that is the portless iphone 13 at least
on the largest pro max model a
completely wireless iphone was
apparently planned for the highest end
iphone in 2021 and it would make sense
to start out with the pro model but it
looks like apple is holding off which
i'm personally really happy about
because of another thing that
unfortunately didn't come to light with
iphone 13s which i was really looking
for and that is better max save
connectivity and charging not only did
we get rumors of this but actual fcc
filings which reveal a new mac safe unit
now the filing doesn't give us too much
info but apple did test it with both 20
watts and 30 watt adapters as we know if
you're using a 20 watt adapter with the
current max safe puck you will achieve a
max output of 15 watts so about a 75
efficiency so with 30 watts that would
give us 22.5 watts or possibly even up
to 25 wireless fast charging if they
improve the efficiency with the new coil
now that would make it even faster than
using a wire charger and that would be
enough to make a fully wireless iphone
possible but unfortunately nope we are
still stuck with lightning instead of
usb type c and even though the battery
inside of the 13 pro max is 18 larger
than last year's even the wired 20 watt
adapter can no longer charge the phone
to 50 in 30 minutes max of charging
isn't any faster like it was rumored to
be so at this point it will take more
than twice as long to wirelessly fast
charge the 13 pro max then with using a
wire charger with that the first reviews
are coming out and the newer stronger
magsafe magnets are nowhere to be seen
in these new iphone 13s now this is
something that i was really excited for
so that i would have a stronger grip for
my wallet with the 13s and to hold my
phone up better with my magsafe mounts
for my car and my truck and the stronger
magnets would be very helpful because
these new iphones have gotten a lot
heavier than last year the smaller 13
pro with its 6.1 is display now weighs
the same exact as the galaxy note 20
ultra with its 6.9 inch display that
thing is big and the pro max is now
getting closer to the fold 3 meaning
that they will have a harder time
holding on to mounted accessories
thankfully cases could help like this
new slim 13 pro max carbon fiber case
from pitaka which i have been testing
with my 12 pro max that kind of fits and
the slim magnets that are in here are
incredibly strong the strongest i've
ever seen now they're not a sponsor or
anything like that but i'll go ahead and
link them down in the video description
the next missing feature that should
have come out with iphone 13s is the
always on display android phones have
had this feature for years and many have
been expecting this since the iphones
have gotten all its screens which was
the iphone 10 but nope this year was
special though because apple switched to
a more power efficient ltpo screen that
can now go all the way down to 10 hertz
saving a lot of battery life and with
that battery slices have also gotten a
lot larger and the a15 and the new modem
chip are also more power efficient so
this year would have been perfect to add
an always on display but of course they
didn't do that even though apple has
offered this for a few years now with
their apple watches and with the series
7 it gets even brighter indoors they do
not want to add this and this is a
softer feature so they could add it but
apple just doesn't want to my guess is
that's just one more thing they're
adding and keeping for the iphone 14
since this year we got a lot of
incremental updates including that 120
hertz promotion display the next feature
is something that was huge news before
the 13's launch and it was a feature
that would set the iphone apart from any
other smartphone and that is support for
satellite connectivity wow and bloomberg
both reported on this being a feature
that could allow you to connect in
places without cellular connectivity now
i've found myself in this spot many
times and it truly does suck especially
if you have an emergency and this would
allow you to send messages through
satellites when you have no service at
all now some people say this could be a
feature that apple just didn't talk
about because it's not ready yet the
hardware is there but it's not enabled
personally i think if it was there apple
would talk about it and they would say
this is coming in the future because
this would be a killer feature so i
think this is going to have to be
something that's going to come out with
an iphone 14 or later once apple has
their own modems ready with that we have
wi-fi 6e which would have been great
even if it was available for just the
pro models samsung's s21 ultra has
support for it even though it came out
about nine months ago and it allows for
the new six gigahertz band to be used
along with the standard 2.4 and 5
gigahertz bands almost everybody has
wi-fi routers now so there is so much
traffic going around that you can have
interference with each other and
slowdowns and this new band would be
like getting an open freeway while
everybody else is in stop and go traffic
and since most people keep their phones
for years it would've been great to see
it in these new iphones but no and the
same thing goes for bluetooth while the
s21 ultra has bluetooth 5.2 now which
has many improvements iphone is still
stuck on bluetooth 5.0 that uses more
power has more interference issues and
lacks new features one thing we really
wanted to see is an implementation of
lossless audio over wireless since apple
has been really pushing lossless with
apple music and the quality difference
over spotify made me sign up for apple
music again we know it's possible
because qualcomm showed off their
lossless audio over bluetooth with aptx
lossless but of course apple doesn't
support the previous aptx codec either
so they would need to make their own
solution but if they are sticking to
bluetooth 5.0 hardware again and again
there simply isn't the hardware there to
allow this to happen and that means that
the upcoming airpods 3 will not support
lossless either so we will have to wait
now one feature that we know is there
but we are not allowed to use is reverse
wireless charging now i was thinking
apple would finally allow us to use it
outside of the magsafe battery pack
since we have larger batteries this year
but nope not yet
let's hope that with those airpods 3
they will roll out a softer update to
finally let us utilize it because that
can be something that is very handy the
last ones are cameras apple made a huge
deal about them at their event they
spent so much time on the larger sensors
the new lenses the new software but the
selfie camera was completely unchanged
now personally i would love to have a
cut down version of the center stage
cameras that they are putting into most
of their tablets now even the cheapest
basic ipad 9 so something that offers a
wider field of view when you need it and
that can also crop in for selfies and
face time the 12 megapixel camera and
the lens are identical to the iphone 12s
so let's hope that the smart hdr4 will
make a big enough difference to catch
apple up to samsung which has been
killing them lately and selfie quality
now we will know soon enough as soon as
we get our hands on the iphone 13s this
friday and we will put the cameras to
the test in our blind camera comparisons
which are always a ton of fun and they
are completely unbiased so if you guys
want to see that click that circle above
to subscribe and with that you guys can
help us reach our goal of 1 million
subscribers we would greatly appreciate
it go ahead and check out one of those
great videos right over there that's
been max and i'll see you in the next
video
[Music]